What if i can't
obi-wan kenobi new episodes streaming wednesdays
only on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this
will be my full obi-wan kenobi episode 4 trailer
video there's a bunch of star wars easter eggs
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes we have a couple big episodes left
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up too careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened on
the series so far if you haven't seen it yet
but we just got our first darth vader versus
obi-wan kenobi rematch although it was a really
quick lightsaber fight it was mostly about obi-wan
kenobi trying to lead darth vader away from malaya
for a lot of different reasons mostly so she could
try to escape like the other many jedi and force
sensitives thank you very much quinlan vos coming
back into the canon there were a couple other
really huge mystery jedi that they revealed in
the arabesh markings on her walls that have since
been decoded so i'll explain who they were because
they're a really big deal but some of you may have
spotted them if you were able to speak arabesh
it's an actual language so it's actually something
that you could decode if you're an expert in that
there were a couple big deep cuts too so if you
saw people talking about mystery jedi names
that are now canon now besides quinlan voss
like there were a bunch of others that's who they
were talking about these mystery jedi that showed
up in the walls in the code obi-wan is also trying
to keep darth vader obviously said focused on him
so that he doesn't start thinking too much about
leia just in general because that would be bad for
a lot of different reasons at this point in the
timeline if darth vader were to learn that lei
or luke were his children it would still mess
with his head in a big way but he's still so
fresh from the events of mustafar revenge of the
sith he's still obsessed with that losing all of
his limbs basically or the rest of his limbs
he's been obsessed with obi-wan kenobi for the
last 10 years he's been trying to snuff out all
of anakin skywalker's identity within him he's
trying to fully adopt this darth vader identity as
the sith lord and he's been hunting jedi killing
most of them for the past ten years and force
sensitives and right now in the timeline where
we're at leia is so young and despite being super
impressionable she's kind of precocious she still
feels like an outsider within her family on
alderaan so even though they tried to make it
clear that they love her a lot she still doesn't
really feel like she's part of their family she
was getting really curious with obi-wan kenobi
about who her real parents were anakin and padme
even though he didn't say their names if she were
to learn that darth vader were really her true
father she would probably run to him not really
thinking about what was going to happen next you
probably don't want to join him because of what
he might do after that they explored some of this
in the legends canon he'd probably take her into
custody and spend the next eight to nine years
between now and the events of the new hope and
rogue one to try and turn her to the dark side
of the force just like the other jedi younglings
like reva she'd basically become like the next
version of reba and she'd be an inquisitor
by the start of a new hope the rebellion
wouldn't have her aid later in the timeline it
would have been way harder for them to get the
death star plans because she wouldn't have been
on her corvette there on scariff to receive them
and eventually obi-wan kenobi would have to train
luke skywalker to fight her some of this may sound
familiar to you who read the legends canon
they actually did a what if star wars story
based on this plot where during the events of the
original trilogy darth vader does wind up making
good on that threat during return of the jedi
like he winds up turning leia to the dark side
when he learns that his children are luke and leia
earlier in the timeline so instead of trying to
turn luke skywalker during empire strikes back he
winds up turning leia instead and you wind up with
a version of return of the jedi where darth vader
fought luke skywalker except it's twin versus twin
it's luke vs leia i do videos for the marvel what
if episodes every season there's going to be a
season 2 later this year too so i'll post links
for all those episodes down in the description
below but this was like star wars version of that
there's also a what if star wars comic book story
where it's what if darth vader turned good earlier
in the timeline and instead of dying during the
events of return of the jedi he changes his sith
armor to white armor because he's turned back to
the light side fully and works with luke skywalker
and leia to hunt down the emperor and the forces
of the empire and destroy them like he winds
up living past the events of return of the jedi
so you'd have to imagine a version of darth vader
who was good again who was fully anakin skywalker
again living during the events of the mandalorian
series the funny thing about that is that grogu
and anakin skywalker are about the same age
that's why we make all the jokes about grogu
also potentially being an interpretation of the
child of the force like the person of prophecy who
will bring balance to the force eventually grogo
is so new to the cannon that he's sort of like
a wrinkle in that whole concept it sounds like
right now in the timeline darth vader will return
to the town where the other inquisitors were and
reva will eventually take leia back to them too
so it'll be interesting to see if leia does wind
up sharing some scenes with actual darth vader
it's really hard to do that without breaking a
ton of cannon but there are ways to accomplish
it for those of you asking about why it seemed
like darth vader also let obi-wan kenobi get away
remember the empire controls the port so nobody
can get off planet as far as they know so he's not
really worried about obi-wan getting away like
he knows it'll be easy to track him down again
so it's kind of like him playing with his food
which is kind of what he did during their fight
he was just kind of leading him along taunting him
the whole way he probably could have killed him
faster if he really wanted to for those of you
asking about the canon between darth vader and
leia though darth vader was able to interrogate
leia during the original trilogy stand right next
to her on frequent occasions like here on the
death star here on her corvette and not realize
that she was actually his biological daughter
he might have been able to sense that she was
force sensitive like feel her through the force
but i think that they're explained that prior to
him reading luke skywalker's mind and literally
learning the truth like reading his mind like oh
you are thinking about her as your sister that
means if you're my son she's my daughter earlier
in the timeline even spending all this time in
proximity to her he never thought about her as
maybe being his child maybe if she had known
padme's name and spoke it in his presence that
would have tipped him off to it but up to this
point she just meant to feel like this random rich
senator's daughter to him that he doesn't really
care about other than she might be force sensitive
they have this weird thing during episode two
where the grand inquisitor talks about the special
rules that they have like what they're actually
allowed to do within the purview of the empire the
grand inquisitor said that capturing a senator's
daughter was a really big deal like potentially it
could cause this giant rift in the senate this
big civil war again like the prequels so the
inquisitors couldn't just go around willy nilly
capturing anybody they felt like they'd have to
drum up some crazy excuse why they had to steal a
senator's daughter and it would still cause them a
bunch of problems if it became super public so in
the name of preserving canon either what they'll
do is they'll just not have them share any really
big scenes together or they'll just flirt with
the idea of him almost finding out that she's his
daughter but based on the footage all these fight
scenes at the fortress inquisitorius it does seem
like obi-wan kenobi goes back there so it kind of
seems like darth vader and the other inquisitors
like reva will take leia back to the fortress
or back to mustafar in his castle and they'll
just make you think that they might eventually
turn her into another dark side inquisitor like
reva they'll just flirt with that idea but then
eventually obi-wan kenobi will rescue her maybe
any other potential jedi younglings or children
that they've already captured there and haven't
turned yet and when leia is older during the
events of rogue one the original trilogy when she
meets darth vader again she'll just think about
him as being this terrible person that tried to
capture her and hurt her earlier in the timeline
without him or the empire truly learning about her
identity but coming close to it but the big thing
with the other secret jedi names that were written
all over this underground railroad room of talas
and quinlan bosses scratched into the walls the
first big one is valen halcyon which is the fake
name given to hal horn in order to hide him from
the inquisitors after order 66 and he is meant to
be the jedi who was the father of koran horn quran
horn is this fan favorite jedi from the legends
canon who is canon now thanks to this big easter
egg he's someone who showed up at luke's jedi
academy during the legends canon so this means the
koran horn is alive and they can use them in any
of the later series in the timeline like the rogue
one prequel series the mandalorian the ahsoka
series anything that takes place during that later
part of the timeline also the little kid on daiyu
that haj's character was trying to help escape
even though he was stealing all their money he
was another force sensitive trying to escape the
inquisitors as part of this underground railroad
his name was credited as koran so it is possible
that he is actually a version of koran horn
at a young age one of the other big secret names
was reganda ismaran and she appeared during the
now canonical children of the jedi book she
was a force-sensitive former consort of emperor
palpatine for those of you wondering who he got it
on with all these years her son with palpatine was
meant to become this sith villain called lord niax
and he was meant to look kind of like palpatine in
his appearance but for those of you wondering
the emperor did have multiple consorts so it
is possible for him to have multiple children out
there in the galaxy one of the other secret names
in the arabesh writing is jin altus he was from
the same children of the jedi book but he led a
splinter group of jedi called the altissian jedi
he wound up being mentored to one of the force
sensitive women that later wound up being a big
love interest for luke skywalker called kalista
ming although we're talking about luke skywalker
getting it on with someone i know everybody is
hoping that eventually they'll canonize mara
jade at some point so we're still waiting on that
but so much of this footage from the trailer and
the concept art seems like it takes place back in
the fortress inquisitorius in the mustafar system
so it does seem like that's where they're going
next week in the final episodes meaning our darth
vader obi-wan rematches will also either happen
back at the fortress inquisitorius or actually
back on mustafar but a lot of that concept art
of them having a rematch seems like a bunch
of lava flows are behind them so it seems like
they really wanted to have a rematch between
them on mustafar let me know in the comments
though do you think that leia actually winds
up being taken back to darth vader's castle and
that's why they have a rematch on mustafar
or do you think they just have a rematch
back on ner where the fortress inquisitorius is my
full obi-wan kenobi episode 4 video will post next
wednesday just like normal the brand new marvel
series is going to be starting that day too so
i'll probably do my obi-wan kenobi episode videos
first then i'll post my marvel episode videos
but also big news the boys season 3 episodes are
also starting right now my full video for the
boy season 3 episode 1 will be next on friday
that'll be a friday show though so that's not
going to overlap with obi-wan episodes or anything
like that on wednesdays make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any
of that it's going to be crazy there's a lot of
really good stuff happening this summer we're
going to be eating good congratulations crazy
kicks you're the giveaway winner from my last big
star wars video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full obi-wan kenobi
episode 3 video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!